Backbone has cycled through each of
the routes in the food router router and
added them to Backbone.history.handlers.
The Backbone.history object
is what actually takes care
of managing the state
of your application.
It monitors the URL for changes, and
when it sees a route that's listed in
its list of handlers,
it calls the function.
Let's take our last dive into Backbone
source to see how it does this.
Let's add a breakpoint here
to pause the execution and
start working through the code.
Reloading pauses at the breakpoint,
so let's step inside start.
These lines determine if the app
can use the hash change and
pushState events to monitor the URL for
changes.
Since we didn't tell
Backbone to use pushState,
it will default to hashChange.
If we want to use pushState,
we could call start like this.
Backbone gets the current
URL fragment here.
This is a precaution in case the app is
loaded with one of the routes already in
the URL.
This section will run if we
said we wanted pushState and
hashChanges also available.
This section will load if
the app is loaded in an iFrame.
Older browsers do not support
the addEventListener API.
So if the app is loaded
in an older browser,
it will set addEventListener to
a function that calls attachEvent.
This section sets up the listener for
either pushState, hashChange, or
if neither one of them is available,
then it fall backs to polling the URL
for changes every 50 milliseconds.
We're checking for the hashChange event,
so we add this listener here.
We're done with this part, so
I'll click Resume to finish
running through all the code.
Now that check URL will be called
when there's a hashChange,
let's set a breakpoint here and
walk through it.
Let's click this button to
change the URL's fragment.
checkUrl gets the current fragment and
calls loadUrl.
loadUrl is what compares the new
URL against the list of handlers.
It gets the current fragment, then it
goes through the list of handlers for
some that have a route that
matches the current URL.
I'll add a breakpoint here to let
us skip over the details of some.
It's paused right here
at the breakpoint.
Checking the scope, we can see that this
handler is the one for the clear route.
It tests the route against the current
page's fragment, and they don't match.
So I'll click Resume to
get to the next handler.
Now it's checking the select route.
Notice fragment right here.
The fragment starts out with select,
so the test does match.
Remember when we walked through what
happens when a router is set up?
This is the callback
function that was created.
This line gets
the parameter from the URL,
then it executes the callback function
that's set up in food router.
After that, it just returns,
and that's it.
We finished digging through how
routing and state management work.
But don't lose track of the big picture.
Backbone.history.start sets up an event
listener to watch the URL for changes.
When it does change, Backbone cycles
through its list of handlers,
looking for one that matches the URL.
When it finds one,
it executes the callback function
associated with that route.